[Music]
okay so hello everyone
uh i'm sam and i just turned 17.
a few years ago before my freshman year
in high school
i wanted to play snare drum in the
foxborough high school marching band
however and it was a dream that i just
had to accomplish
but each snare drum and harness weighed
about 40 pounds each
and i have a disease called progeria so
just to give you an idea
i weigh about only 50 pounds so
logistically i really couldn't carry a
regular size snare drum
and because of this the band director
assigned me to play
pit percussion during the halftime show
now pit percussion was fun uh it
involved some really cool
auxiliary percussion instruments like
the bongos
timpani and timbales and cowbell
so it was fun um but it involved no
marching
and i was just so devastated
however nothing was going to stop me
from playing snare drum with the
marching band
in the halftime show so my family and i
worked with an engineer
to design a snare drum harness
that would be lighter and easier for me
to carry
and so after continuous work
we made a snare drum apparatus that
weighs only about six pounds
i'm just going to give you some more
information about progeria
it affects only about 350 kids today
worldwide so it's pretty rare and
effects of progeria include tight skin
lack of weight gain stinted growth
and heart disease last year my mom and
her team of scientists
published the first successful progeria
treatment study
and because of this i was interviewed on
npr
and john hamilton asked me the question
what is the most important thing
that people should know about you and my
answer was
simply that i have a very happy life
even though there are many obstacles in
my life
with a lot of them being created by
progeria i don't want people to feel bad
for me
i don't think about these obstacles all
the time and i'm able to
overcome most of them anyway so i'm here
today to share with you
my philosophy for a happy life so for me
there are three aspects to this
philosophy
so this is a quote from the famous
ferris bueller
the first aspect to my philosophy is
that i'm okay with what i ultimately
can't do
because there's so much that i can do
now people sometimes ask me questions
like
isn't it hard living with progeria or
what daily challenges of progeria do you
face
and i'd like to say that even though i
have progeria
most of my time is spent thinking about
things that have nothing to do with
progeria at all
now this doesn't mean that i ignore the
negative aspects
of these obstacles when i can't do
something like
run a long distance or go on an intense
roller coaster
you know i know what i'm missing out on
but instead
i choose to focus on the activities that
i can do
for things that i'm passionate about
like scouting
or music or comic books or any of my
favorite boston sports teams
yeah so
however sometimes i need to find a
different way to do something
by making adjustments and i want to put
those things
in the can-do category kind of like you
saw with the drum earlier
so here's a clip with me playing
spider-man
with the foxboro high school marching
band at halftime a couple years ago
[Music]
so
[Music]
thank you all right all right
so that was pretty cool uh
and so i was able to accomplish my dream
of playing scenario drum with the
marching band as i believe i can do for
all of my
dreams so hopefully you can accomplish
your dreams as well
with this outlook the next aspect to my
philosophy is
that i surround myself with people that
i want to be with
people of high quality i'm extremely
lucky
to have an amazing family who have
always supported me throughout my entire
life
and i'm also really fortunate to have a
really close group of friends at school
now we're kind of goofy a lot of us are
banned geeks
but we really enjoy each other's company
and
we help each other out when we need to
we see each other for who we are
on the inside so this is us goofing off
a little
bit and so we're juniors in high school
now
and we can now mentor
younger band members um as a single
collective unit
what i love about being in a group like
the band is that the music that we make
together
is true it's genuine and
it supersedes progeria so i don't have
to worry about that
when i'm feeling so good about making
music
even having made a documentary going on
tv a couple times
i feel like i'm at my highest point when
i'm with the people that surround me
every day
they provide the real positive
influences in my life
as i hope that i can provide a positive
influence in theirs as well
thank you so the bottom line here is
that i hope that you appreciate
and love your family love your friends
for you guys love your bros
and acknowledge your mentors
and your community because they are very
real aspects of everyday life
that can make a truly significant
positive impact
so the third aspect to the philosophy is
keep moving forward here's a quote
by a man you may know named walt disney
and it's one of my favorite quotes
i always try to have something to look
forward to
something to strive for to make my life
richer it doesn't have to be big
it could be anything from looking
forward to the next comic book to come
out or going on a large family vacation
or hanging out with my friends to go
into the next high school football game
however all of these things keep me
focused
and know that there's a bright future
ahead and may get me through some
difficult times
that i may be having now this mentality
includes
staying in a forward thinking state of
mind
i try hard not to waste energy feeling
badly for myself
because when i do i get stuck in a
paradox
where there's no room for any happiness
or any other emotion
now it's not that i ignore when i'm
feeling badly
i kind of accept it i let it in
so i cannot acknowledge it and do what i
need to do to move past it
when i was younger i wanted to be an
engineer
i wanted to be an inventor who would
catapult the world into a better future
maybe this came from my love of legos
and the freedom of expression that i
felt
when i was building with them
and these was also derived from my
family and my mentors who always make me
feel whole
and good about myself now today my
ambitions have changed a little bit
i'd like to go into the field of biology
maybe
cell biology or genetics or
biochemistry or really anything and
this is a friend of mine who i look up
to
francis collins the director of the nih
and this is us at ted med last year
chatting away
i feel that no matter what i choose to
become
i believe that i can change the world
and as i'm striving to change the world
i will be happy
about four years ago hbo began to film a
documentary
about my family and me called life
according to sam
now it was a pretty great experience but
it was also four years ago
and like anyone my views on many things
have changed and hopefully matured
like my uh potential career choice
however
some some things have stayed the same
throughout that time
like my mentality and philosophy towards
life
so i would like to show you a clip of my
younger self
from the film that i feel embodies that
philosophy
i know more about it genetically
so it's less of an embodiment now
it used to be like this thing that
prevents me from doing all this stuff
that causes other kids to die that
causes everybody to be stressed and now
it's um you know a protein
that is abnormal that weakens the
structure of cells
so and it takes a burden off of me
because now i
don't have to think about progeria as
an entity
okay pretty good huh yep
thank you so as you can see i've been
thinking this way for many years
but i never really had to apply all of
these aspects
of my philosophy to the test at one time
until last january
i was pretty sick i had a chest cold and
i was in the hospital for a few days
but and i was secluded from all the
aspects of my life that i felt
made me me that kind of gave me my
identity
but knowing that i was going to get
better
and looking forward to a time that i
would feel good again helped me to keep
moving forward
and sometimes i had to be brave and it
wasn't always easy
sometimes i faltered i had bad days
but i realized that being brave isn't
supposed to be easy
and for me i feel it's the key way to
keep moving forward
so all in all i don't waste energy
feeling bad
for myself i surround myself with people
that i want to be with
and i keep moving forward so with this
philosophy
i hope that all of you regardless of
your obstacles
can have a very happy life as well oh
wait hang on a sec
one more uh piece of advice
never miss a party if you can help it my
school's homecoming dance is tomorrow
night
and i will be there thank you very much
you